έβλεπετετις ανάγκες τις αγοράς και μάλιστα ενα πτυχείό που σχεδιάζεται σήμερα μπορείς σε πέντεαι κα
χρόνια να μην έχει ουσία και συμασία για την αγορά εργασία αρά πρέπει σε πραγματικό
χρόνο να γίνονται κάποια πράγμα δυστυχώς ι γράφειο κρατία αλλά και ι αργοί μετα άλλαξη
των πρόγραμμάτων των πανεπιστιγμείων και τον καδημαϊκώ ιδρημάδω πολλές φορές έχει κόστος γιατί τελειώνι ανασφιτητής
έχει ψηλές προσδοκίες και αγορά ν αντααποκρίνε ατηλοδογία και να μιασουδί μετά πό πέντεξι χρόνια
πυ τα γιώνητες πουδές τους σίγουρα μια αγορα είναι πολύ διαφορετική άρα ποιο συγκακριμένος στίτλως
ηίσως α είναι αυτό που υπεςσότι μετά γω παέντεξι χρόνια μα εν έχει την ίδια
παρίτητα που είχε ακρίβως και για πάρα πολλα χρόνια επίσεις το άλλο πρόβλημα όλοι ήθελαν
να πουστο δημόσιο και στις τράπεζας αυτή ήταν ι κύπρος για πάρα πολλές δεκαϊτίας τεράστει
ι κατάλογοι η καθηγητν ακόμη τώρα τους παίρνουν τηλέφωνο στα πενήντς στα πενήτα έντε να
πας καθηγητής μα κάποιος πους πούδάσες τα είκοση και έμεινε εκτός του πλαισίου για πάρα
πάρα πολλέ χρόνια ίνι πολύ δύσκολο να είναι ένα καλώς καθηκή της τα πενήντας τα
πμπορεί να είναι αλλά είναι πολύ πιο δύσκολο τα πράγματα αλλάζουν πάρα πολύ γρήγορα ανδεν
είσε ενημερουμένος για το τής συμβένλιβος είναι πολύ δύσκολο είναι και εδώ που έχουμε και
εμείς μιώθουμε περήφανεί ότι έχουμε συνισφέρει το δικό μας κομμάτι γιατί εμείς αννακάτημα ικό ήτρημα
εστιαστεί κάμε στους εργαςσεργαζόμενος φιτητές αρά τα πάντα γίνονται με πραγματικό χρόνο το βράδυς που
δάζεις ται πόμενο μπορέ προί μπορείς να εφαρμόσεις κάποια πράγματα που έχεις διδακτεί το το
βράδυ χρειάζεται το πάντρεμα του ακαδημαϊκού και του επαγγελματικού κόσμου όχι απλά να να έχουμε
πολος αποβιτούς γιατί το άλλο μεγάλομ πρόβλημα για πάρα πολλές δεκαϊτίες περιφανευόμαστο δεέχουμε πολύ ψει
λόδείκτη αποφείτον ται τοβάθουμε σεκπέίδρις ανότες ε κπαδς αλλά δε συμενιτίποτα αυτό είναι σωστό ότι
πρέει να υπάρχουν οι δέξειότητες να είσαι να να έχεις μια συσχέτηση με τοτι χρειάζεται
ια αγοράτα επόμενα πντεται κα χρόνια και βλέπουμε και με την